thank you
that's the right song for this segment
the self-made jewelry Mogul Kendra Scott
created a billion dollar business
starting with just 500 it's true back in
2002 Scott turned her jewelry making
hobby into the Kendra Scott brand
working out of a spare bedroom in her
home her mom was there to help that was
employee number one basically over the
next 20 years she changed the jewelry
world with her iconic designs and
affordable prices a good combo there now
Scott is out with the Memoir Born To
Shine do good find your joy and build a
life you love she shares her life's
journey to success and the lessons she's
learned along the way and Kendra Scott
joins us now welcome
she's matching her book cover I love it
everything is something yellow every day
at the store so and I know it's Gail's
favorite color
Dale's River color and you're one of her
favorite designers I know she wears a
lot of your stuff she would love to be
here uh you know usually when a person
writes a book you ask him what's the
inspiration for the book You're the
Inspiration
all the stuff you've done why'd you want
to put it down on paper you know I think
for me it was 20-year anniversary so
this is 20 years of my business going
through 2020 as we all know was such a
difficult time and I think from the
outside world everyone was looking at me
going Kendra Scott she's on top of the
world everything's great but I was also
going through a personal low and I had
been journaling so many things and I
thought there's power and vulnerability
there's power to say that let's share
the UPS the Downs the failures that led
to a success many times you hear people
say you have to fail before you succeed
but you don't really hear the story of
how that happened and I thought if I
could be vulnerable and share those
things maybe others could feel like they
could as well you know I started making
jewelry about 20 years ago I spent about
500 bucks on my first outing all right
and I gave it up after about five months
I've never heard that before oh yeah so
why how did you keep it going I mean you
had a Vision obviously but you couldn't
have imagined this kind of success never
in a million years I mean starting out
of that extra bedroom literally hand
beating everything going store to store
in Austin Texas with my baby son in a
little baby carrier you're getting a lot
of no's at first totally I mean I
fortunately Texans are nice but a few
stores said no and I had to get back in
and go and try to do it again 10 years I
tried to get investment Capital nobody
would invest in me yeah I was in a tech
driven City you're a designer out of
Texas like nobody was interested so a
lot of no's along the way but still
having that perseverance I was a single
mom my boys were one in three in the
early stages of building my business and
I think looking at them looking at their
little faces it was like I can't give up
I have to keep moving forward one step
in front of the other every single day
and you'd get some wins along the way
you know I think you'd get a few people
to believe in you and you'd go okay hey
maybe there is something here you know
and that would give you another little
bit of fuel in the tank to keep fighting
another day yeah like I say Texans uh
they're nice they'll politely turn you
down say oh bless your heart oh I've
been told no so many different ways it's
unbelievable let me tell you it's like
not right now not right now we'll call
you yeah um but you you keep alluding to
the missteps and not just the UPS but
the Downs what are some of those
missteps for young entrepreneurs that
are watching right now saying I'm just
stubbing my toe and I can't get out of
my own way what were some of those
moments for you you know my first
business I had it for five years it was
a hat company I did headwear for men and
women undergoing chemotherapy but then
also sold every hat you could imagine
and after five years of running that
business I had to close it and hats were
not the next big thing I thought they
were I wanted it to be like 1940 again
that didn't work out and I had to close
that business was it a misstep or was it
actually the foundation for my next
thing that did work right if I hadn't
had the hat box if I hadn't had that
failure I wouldn't it would be it
wouldn't get be where I went it was the
bridge that I needed all those lessons
so many things I learned in that
experience to build the successful
company I have today so I tell
entrepreneurs or anyone going through a
difficult time think about failing
forward that if we don't go through
these things in our life we can't learn
the things we need to learn because
something better is waiting for you and
this stubbed toe is going to get you
there it's going to get you there yeah
keeping that in mind mine just last year
you stepped back from being CEO of
Kendra Scott we went into that you know
20 years of CEO is it was a great run
right but I have built this amazing team
and one of the things I've realized over
my 20-year Journey as founder I'm
executive chairwoman and still majority
shareholder of Kendra Scott is that use
the strengths that you're given and find
people that are great at the things that
you're not great at to fill in those
holes the more I could focus on the
vision of the brand for the next 20
years the philanthropic side of our
company we started a school at the
University of Texas for women the
women's entrepreneur and Leadership
School we've done so many cool things
that now I'm able to do write a book and
share our story but also still being
designer being in the stores more
meeting my customers and creating the
future of Kendra Scott yeah I want to
talk about that Tick Tock tell her ask
her about this I don't know we have time
Alabama sorority Tick Tock videos are in
like every single one how's that feel
unbelievable well I mean when they're
like Kendra Scott Kendra Scott it's
unbelievable it's so great and so
flattering I never gets old to see
people wearing my jewelry I'm loving it
I got some jewelry here of yours you're
gonna have to show me how to how to
lengthen these out so I can go yeah
thank you very much
right now we will be right back thank
you